[Music]
food to Casimir form all the ingredients
in this dish are cooked sous-vide in a
water bath it's professor inside a
vacuum pack the fish takes 15 minutes
chicken wings take 12 hours and if it
good takes time I think along so we can
see a great end result then it's worth
all the time the wall next to herbes you
a blend of chives chervil and parsley is
pureed finally sift and then placing
this machine that creates a vacuum
removing all the air bubbles we use this
all the time possibly there's no more
way in four days thinks the rest in the
fridge to the outcomes I you see now is
pure I've criticized Casimir for
overusing the water bath because not all
ingredients suited so have they learned
their lesson the whole secret is just to
finish it in a pan and just let this
skin just crisp it create our
caramelized Tori flavor in it
unbelievable
absolutely water it's great news because
customers are comfortable with pan
frying but it's just one more stage in
an already complicated process the key
thing is the timing of everything yeah
at the time it's not that much be
screwed
this is beautiful refined cooking
simplicity on the plate achieved with
technical precision and attention to
detail processor you know quarter of
110% and it pushes you all the way not
only does he want to be some
communication but he wants the dish it's
not that perfect obviously see tonight
we've got like people chef's table that
we've got please and the rest of the
doughnuts so absolutely mad experience
kazimierz main course is a complicated
dish and it will demand the kind of
teamwork they haven't shown yet the boys
are still infuriatingly slow getting
food out I need to see some form of
[ __ ] teamwork going on there's one
thing I've got with you guys is a stop
start stop start you've gotta get 21st
century flow it's nice to push the boat
out we've gotta get your flow yes
finally they seem to be hitting their
stride just like ever the sauce and the
food looks amazing but how has the
unusual combination of chicken and fish
gone down with my diners sober was an
excellent I think this absolutely sound
to choice that they made the turbot was
perfect the chicken wings were really
good and the satisfy brought it all
together the creaminess in the middle
again it's why I expect because I mean
they're very clever they know what
they're doing and he was executed
let's go whew that's what it looks
fantastic guys keep it going yes chef
whilst the boys daring dish has really
impressed
upstairs their parents so say so say are
clearly feeling the strain
but on the pillar for the other lady
with banco still to go will they be able
to hold it together
I'm feel a little bit under pressure a
little bit
this is Gordon Ramsay the best
restaurant to do the best time to find
out what my experts on the chef's table
thought of customers main course
I think elements on that plate were
fantastic from Casimir I love the roast
it's also quite I'm not the way they
used to travel on the plate I thought
that was delicious and fantastic
combination did you brought the whole
thing together season the whole plates
perfect yeah I thought it was a good
effort
yeah it sounds to be pure always
delicious the roasted sounds we show up
and experience when they're hard you
know they gave it perfectly I know being
really reinvented they're coming up with
new dishes specifically for this
competition eyes